السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره قالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه انها ثلاثه شهداء سقطوا
بالرصاص الاحتلال خلال اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال بلده جبع في قضاء جنين وقال شهود
عيان ان القوات الاسرائيليه الخاصه اطلقت
النار على مركبه كان يستقلها فلسطينيون
ثلاثه وكانت قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه قد
تسللت الى داخل البلده وفتحت نيرانا
اسلحتها على الفلسطينيين
وفي جنينه ايضا شيعها للمدينه وفي مخيم
عسكر بنابلس جثامينا سته شهداء سقطوا
برصاص قوات الاحتلال يوم الثلاثاء
اعرب بيان للاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلق بالغ
اذا اتزايد العنف في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله ودعا البيان القاده الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين الى تهدئه الموقف والامتناع
عن الاجراءات التي تزيد مستوى التوتر
في اوكرانيا قالت الاداره العسكريه
روسيه استهدفت مدينه ومحيطها من جهته قال
عمده المدينه ان الغارات استهدفت منشات
للطاقه في خاركيد وهو ما تسبب في انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي عن عدد من الاحياء
المدينه كما افادت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
ان محطه نوويه من دون كهرباء بعد الضربه
الروسيه
من جهتها قالت الاداره العسكريه في مدينه
قصفا صاروخيا روسيا استهدف البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في المدينه وافادت الاداره
العسكريه في كييفن الدفاعات الجويه تصدقت
لاهداف جويه في سماء العاصمه وقد ذكرت
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه ان محطه النوويه
اصبحت من دون كهرباء بعد الضربه الروسيه
على المنطقه
قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان المعركه
التي يقودها بالقانون بالضمن عاثوا فسادا
بالبلاد ستستمر بنفس القوه وفق تعبيره
مضيفا انه سيتم اصداره الامر المتعلق
بدعوه مجلس النواب للانعقاد احتراما
للمواعيد التي تم قطعها واضاف انه سيتم حل
المجالس البلديه كلها سيتم ايضا تعويضها
بنيابات خصوصيه وسيتم النظر في مشروعي
مرسومين يتعلقان بتنقيح القانون الانتخابي
للمجالس البلديه ومشروع يتعلق بانتخاب
اعضاء مجلس الجهات والاقاليم
قالت مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه
لنيران اقتربت بشكل خطير من صنع قنبله
النوويه اضافه ان ايرانه زادت من وتيره
برنامجها النووي واجرت بحوثا وانشطه تطوير
تقربها من انتاج المواد اللازمه لصنع سلاح
النووي
في جورجيا تعمل الشرطه على تفريق متظاهرين
تجمعوا امام مقر البرلمان في العاصمه
وقد وقعت اشتباكات عنيفه بين محتجين على
ما يعرف بقانون العملاء الاجانب والشرطه
يقول المعارضون لمشروع القانون انه اداه
لترهيب وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه
اشكركم على متابعه هذا المودز كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]